[Music]
watch your head don't don't make it ruin
your organization
move your hips as you going through down
at the edge know you're pole-vaulting on
the front leg shift your weight shift
your weight no shift your weight
come to come see she's in tight here
your feet are not in a natural stance
you're in hanmi you see you have a
bracing angle on your back foot
watch your chest
[Music]
to keep the crown of your head at the
high point and alignment with your spine
and so if that's the case that bites not
a matter of my head tucking in my chest
going in you're doing hip rotation
I don't I'm not working on this time you
think I'm still doing my cuts they still
they still do to my cut so my kite
doesn't go like this
just testing like my body spoon I'll buy
it on my cutting structure you see my
feet are going to be under my hip and
I'm not going here so I don't even worry
about the arm doing anything my body is
going to hit you know a shift though I
don't walk like this
oh I shift and I move in
shift lock everything don't don't do
anything just hit him with your body
[Music]
it's not it's not the cutting timing
it's just the structure of the cutting
structure okay so hold shift I'm moving
are you trying to sell you trying to do
marriage was graphic yeah remember when
you were taught that I told you that
that doesn't have to be the case you're
an abrasive angle see your back foot
are you doing hip rotations you're
trying to move them back rather than
test your structure so you think you're
thinking you're telling yourself cut but
it's not you're you're just trying to
move them back and the justification is
I'll I'm doing the cutting timing so
you're hitting him when your back foot
hits the ground like as if you were
doing the cutting timing but if you paid
attention I have my back foot it was
still in movement okay cuz I'm just
testing structure in do you have a
bracing angle bring that foot in because
it has depth has nothing to do with this
depth height nothing to do with this
does their beginner doorways you brought
your foot in it again so you're trying
to use penetration penetration has
nothing to do with this you you don't
you have a bracing angle your feet
aren't under your hips
you got that stiff leg stiff leg you
stopping your Center for moving forward
first
[Music]
your knees concaving again you're doing
hip rotation
watch where you're looking
these are pushing her
[Music]
pick this time he's not gonna be at that
sweet spot where he wanted where you
want to be okay so like he's gonna be
close to you can't see that so I'm just
keeping the same structure he's he's
much closer keep the same structure do
the same drill okay your arm is going
don't change the elbow angle leave it
out leave it out better
he's nearing your sweet spot Jamo up
again
we're doing hip rotation
is that you get it to have faith on this
you're doing back foot
your elbow bent so if your arm stays
it's given length and you move into the
space then he must be displaced from
that so there's no pushing of him do you
see that he's not going to be there the
only way you can push on him is if you
didn't displace him so if I'm not if I'm
not pushing him then I don't need the
hip rotation or the back foot do you
understand I see you you before you guys
push him you already lost the structure
and that's why you have to push him okay
go now hold extension like somebody's
doing the first drill on your left arm
where we push into that foot that arm
just leave it out it's kind of bent and
the elbow is kind of flaring on you oh
you're a hand caved in
it's caving in
lock your lats pull your lats down
I'm gonna get that foot off the line
right that's part of the drill the back
foot it's not movable on you because
you're pushing with it
watch your head angle at the beginning
your head angle is very important
because it's going to pull you off
organization so you might see my head go
down I could stick my head wherever I
want
if you can't
if your hand caved in that's when you go
to the pushing so look if this is not
that hard
do you see that they get out you're
you're imagining too much pipe then you
give good you going stay to please you
coming in here and you're hitting that
and then you see my arm change this
angle my arms changing this ankle and
now in order to get this to extend
you're going like this you could be on
it and he's going to move
you can you can hit him on the sweet
spot we're not doing but in between in
between but keep the same extension
shift move lock okay it's not it's not
different because 20 feet it's not
different because he's tiny because only
I had a lighter phone he doesn't feel
any different
he actually feels heavier than here so
no do you see you cut you coming in and
you get ready to push
leave your arm here do the drugs okay
did you see your back foot put it move
so ground paths cannot be always aiming
down on the back foot these are just
beginner references
to resist resist the temptation hold
your own structure watch the back foot
back
remember how little it takes I just
change your mind you know your arm is PJ
relax
Jin is not sleeping
during hip rotation the hip rotation
happens in the foot maneuver
[Music]
so it's not that you can't use hit me
never say he does whatever right just
come in right I have this little hip
change here if you see that and I think
that will keep me closer right I won't
have to be far away you see that same
thing if I was here right and I wanted
to hit him boom I could I could get my
hips going right home to do different
things so I'm not saying that's out of
it but that's not what we're doing here
and a lot of Aikido Kevon Wazza yeah has
the hips that rotate are rotating in the
movement that you're using as a whole
body so you don't ever have you see when
I rotate my hips if you pay attention
why is that happening because my
shoulders are going the other way do you
see that okay or if you leave my
shoulders where they are and you turn
your hips why is that
appearing to you like a hip rotation
because my feet and even ami see that so
that's not what's happening so if I if
my hips are rotating this many degrees
from here to over there
in Aikido you're gonna do it with your
whole body
do you see how I did that and then and I
don't have to switch this way and leave
anything behind so as you guys are doing
this you're going look
if you left it behind see that and so he
makes contact with me right now go go
ahead right I am NOT as locked out so
you go ahead and you leave it behind and
that's how you can bring it bring it in
but if he gives me energy right you're
gonna find that when you leave it behind
there you have a lower ceiling of
performance boom to try to get that to
move it's not that you can but your
performance envelope is going down right
whereas if we're here and I never leave
it behind never leave it behind it's
easy you see that and so my hip rotation
is from the overall body movement you
want your hips to rotate they rotate in
the movement is the movement you see
that that's why you don't do this one
that that was my leg disconnected from
my hip I didn't whine my hips I didn't
disconnect my my hips from my legs I
disconnected my leg from my hips you see
that so no the movement does it
there is a hip rotation but it's from
the whole body moving as a union yeah so
careful because in your in your lust to
make your move you're doing that
he's oh yes I'm not using the hip
rotation I'm not using the bracing angle
so I just begin to show you I don't need
the back foot I don't even need to coach
the extension right I don't need this
you can have it little doesn't matter
[Music]
one foot means no toe on the ground
training means integrity
[Music]
you're leaning
li means I can only do so much
you have to hold yourself to the form I
can only take away so many cheats
Virginia go back to the form just do the
same thing
Sammis Xing with your hand now wait say
it in your head with my hand now your
nut back to the other thing we see you
used your foot when are you back to your
hips
can we shut that door
we go back to the drill ashita batter
batter
watch your head angle don't look in and
be a little bit further you're leaning
you're hitting them on two feet tight
then lifting it up after the fact
do you see that wobble in the middle
right hip rotation the hip rotations
with the movement not by disconnecting
the hips
watch that head angle
it's loose in the middle and the lower
leg stiffness is in the way again
work on the on this this part that's
having problems okay so he's gonna help
me and I'm just I'm testing that corner
right I'm testing the locking of those
relationships and he's pushing in in
this case unfortunately I going to use
the back foot it obviously it's not
about two feet or the battery okay so
he's just testing me and once I get
there I'm going to disconnect the first
two do you see how I did that and then
back it's not a true disconnect of the
first to be because I'm not going super
far so there is the width of my feet
where my hips and knees can stay within
the foot angle so I'm here like this and
he's pushing you could tell him push
hard push hard push hard and you know
you're doing it right if he lets go
really fast and you're not flying
forward oh so if you if you're doing
that right tell your your person hey you
come on get out of the bracing angle so
he's there right and so I'm gonna work
within those me the knee angle do you
see how I'm doing that it's starting to
turn do you see that do you guys see
that okay see I don't know I'm not
facing him well I didn't collapse so I'm
just going to give some conditioning to
it
get yourself grounded so you're
connected
then you're going to turn stay within
the foot angle right and then you're
going to turn back which is going to be
pretty heavy okay let's try that right
[Music]
we want some play in the knee hip angle
but no play in the shoulder hip angle
[Music]
okay so I'm just gonna write to do this
there has to be a relaxation in the in
the knee part right all right okay so
obviously holding myself like this is
not it to eat there okay so we're gonna
work on that relaxation that release so
I he's locked in to me right I'm gonna
release just a little bit and push back
here just release probably a little less
than I went and push back don't look for
a big movement out of him is you're
gonna lose the form it's just you're
trying to do a rep okay no he's I got to
contact right
he's pushing if you feel you need more
energy you can ask for it and okay
you have a hip disconnect
[Music]
hip rotation
Manor
[Music]
you try to get your moving inside less
outside outside movements getting you're
gonna be forced to disconnect us those
three spheres shoulders hips knees
they're gonna be disconnected you don't
want that inside and you feel your
shoulder moving as because what the next
one you're gonna you're gonna really not
so now now as your your partner has to
have cocoa and say you soft middle
people you can you might not I might to
divide you up where you guys can just
screw off on your own but he has to he
has to get to me in the same way that we
were doing this word girl right so I am
going to boom do that same thing I was
doing but in the timing of him hitting
me and so you'll get a small bout so on
the boom it's not this where I'm stiff
and he goes only do you see it's not
that okay so he comes in there's a boom
okay let's try
don't let your elbow Bend you have to
set yourself up to feel it
[Music]
it's not just a matter of being a big
wall that they run into there's an
absorption element your elbow is flaring
you can hit the corner and we're testing
for that corner you feel like you're not
using torque here whoa he's not getting
out of the way
of your strike you understand you're
bringing them in bringing his body
[Music]
[Applause]
into the same way as the first drill I
yield the same way and project like the
second drill no we're not what I'm
trying to tell you he's not taking can
be to save himself his new kidney is
only at the bottom hey tuck your chin
and don't die so I can get more rested
yeah but he's not he's not diving under
and I'm absorbing him
[Music]
you wanna set them up to stay straight
straight
you try to find the entry though that's
it now you're getting the in space and
now the head target is starting to show
[Music]
that's it what I'm coming in release
you're fine pull out Chris that's not
your job
[Music]
not only gonna work if you're stronger
than him if you're not stronger than him
that's just skis gonna get pissed
because he just smacked him in the face
he just wanted to hold her on it but now
you hit him in the face he's gonna knock
you out
he was like what time is it what you
just hit me in the throat now you're
gonna shoulder inter you missed the head
because she's not actually connected to
you that's the only way you can go over
there now you have to aim please better
try to calm down
[Music]